halo 5 guardians comes out today destiny
I guess it finally came out about two
weeks ago 15 like a year and yeah yeah
sorry I'm an independent adjudicator and
sound very independent in this
conversation hi
are you doing we're here to talk about
destiny I'm Halo 5 which is the better
first-person online multiplayer /
single-player experience for your home
video game consoles I'm joined by Eric
Tay I'm up what's up like my hearty how
you doing good how are you I'm doing
great I'm looking forward to this one
yeah all right both of you play both yes
tell you have played the campaign for
Halo 5 you've played more destiny than I
have hot hot meals my entire life and
Mike you reviewed taken King and destiny
sorry and guardians guardians halo 5
guardians for guess what calm yeah and
we're here to talk about which one's
better first of all I want to talk about
I guess where this all kind of starts
which for me is with campaign or lease
that's the traditional way we've had it
destiny has a sort of a non-traditional
or like online experience at Halo
obviously is more traditional campaign
and Mike first of all I'm gonna go with
you why do you think Halo 5 is a better
campaign than destiny considering in
your review for Halo 5 you didn't think
that campaign was all that good yeah
this is so I didn't think the story was
that great the campaign itself is well
designed and fun to play and they
introduced this new level design I think
my love for Halo just stems from how fun
it is to just play and destiny feels
great but in my opinion and in my
experience in that it's just destiny is
just constantly shooting a bunch of
different enemies in the head yeah
taking King did a little bit better by
introducing these new enemy types of
head abilities but still the best way to
kill them was just to shoot them in the
face which halo like you can say the
same for that I'm sure but you sure can
each different enemy like has these more
subtle ways that change how you play and
the firefights all kind of unfold
differently and feel different to me
each time because you have so many
different I mean destiny you have these
pot like the supers you can use but Halo
especially in Halo 5 you have the ground
pound you have the smash
and you're rubbing your neck already man
it's not a good sign okay you're shaking
your head what do you think okay let's
talk about the ground and pound and
shoulder charge first of all both
tighten abilities one of the clashes in
destiny that came out first obviously
and in terms of story yeah it took us a
little while to get to where we were
what is decibel yeah took a little
division yeah I showed you know uh but
it took a while to get there you know I
think they learned a lot as you said
with taking King a lot more just
continuity in between missions there's
more storytelling you know little
cinematic trailers or trait like not
trailers but little cinematics
in-between just storytelling better just
better like back and forth with the
NPC's and I think part of it too is that
destiny is evolving right and it's it's
the rate is kind of the the harder
portion of the the story is where you
end up at right because that's where the
big bad boss is and that's where all the
kind of bigger mechanics are right that
are outside of just you're shooting
things in the head or in the gut but I
mean it's the same in Halo like there's
a night you're shooting him in the
armpit so that his head opens up yeah
I'm shooting of X in the stomach like
it's kind of the same thing but I think
with destiny there's a little bit more
to it because you do have your supers as
as a sub clutter and your sub classes
for each KH class and then on top of
that with the taken enemies this time
around they have different things that
they do captains will throw blind balls
at you you have to avoid it and so
there's I feel like there's more like
movement than in Halo where it's like
you're just hiding more in Halo I guess
all right any interested of making sure
everyone has the same amount of time I'm
gonna pass the back over to Mike to
retort to that and you have to say about
that yeah so I don't in Halo 5 if you
were to are you really just hiding
behind cover and then shooting a pop-out
shoot well yeah because when you play
campaign by yourself with three dumb AI
if you die a paper then you chances are
you're done for right is destiny a fun
solo experience no I think it's okay at
least it's it scales a little bit better
and like I think you're less frustrated
from the fact like if you die you know
why you died
right and like it's like halo you kind
of just feel like so much of your robot
revived you well no that's but that's if
you get down in halo that's your fault
it's not it's not your fault in the AI
is too dumb to revive you but it's every
time I got down I was like oh it's
because I ran into the middle this room
and like you're safe yeah that's your
safety net that's not why you're done
yeah it's more of it's just more of
their attempt to keep it going instead
of just checkpoint checkpoint checkpoint
if it's really tough but halo especially
in Halo 5 more than any other Halo you
have so many options laid out before you
like you can run up this run up a path
to a ground pound from below sprint at
the next grunt Spartan smash him across
turn around
obviously far a few shots your battle
rifle and throw a grenade which like
destiny does have that movement but I
felt I actually played destiny more of
like take cover and then shoot at these
enemies who would take varying amounts
of bullets to kill which again taking
king did improve on that but I still
felt like Halo that these subtle nuances
they added to the movement just
completely changed how I looked in maps
especially because the map design was I
think there's more focus on creating a
good level whereas you know Destiny's a
lot more open than Halo 5 which I don't
they're not going for the same thing but
I think I personally prefer halo 5 style
which is sort of linear but these arenas
were you can kind of like it's like a
playground almost and kind of get on
this turret or you know getting this
Banshee that you just found or just
completely find this new weapon cache
you don't even know existed whereas you
know you're more attached to your
characters and destiny because it's an
RPG and you're you're getting new
weapons and you're getting new powers
that your character up until certain I
don't know how are they appreciate let's
move away from the campaign stuff to
talk about multiplayer Eric I'm gonna
let you have first swing on this one
obviously Halo more traditional
multiplayer experience different game
modes but you know isolated from the
campaign what is it about destiny you
think that makes it a better multiplayer
experience in the halo 5 Guardians I
think on top playing max in Halo sport
right for people that you can party up
with so in destiny you can do 6 and
co-op and co-op yeah yeah if you're
playing ah and like in one of the other
modes you can have like 12 buddies right
yeah easily okay well well I don't think
so I'm out co-op campaign your time well
I'm talking about multiplayer though can
you have more than 4 in your party in
arena you can only have 4 but you can
have in a fireteam no but you'll be like
with five at least
other people but in warzone you could
have a little your friend can have eight
other people in addition to your three
friends ya know but in addition to his
friend so what I'm trying to say is that
in destiny you can party up to six
people which is two people more than
halo so you can get more buddies in that
you know that you want to play with it
maybe four people sign up to is more but
it doesn't necessarily mean that sure
that's fine but then I would like I like
to bring in Giancarlo or Josh to my raid
because you can do six people raids that
you can't do in Halo and I think that's
one of the big proponents there and I
think that multiplayer is ever-evolving
in destiny and one of the things is
that's pretty cool too is there's a
commitment from Bungie to keep patching
and making things better so like when
pvp gets out of hand if a gun is out of
hand or guns are out of hand they will
patch that and they will fix it and
they've been they've been doing that
more and more and more and on top of
that because of how destiny is set in
this world they can do fun events like
the Halloween event just happen
yesterday like nobody saw it coming and
it's just this cool little thing that
everyone gets to try out like you don't
even have to have a fireteam or anything
you can just do it on your own and
experience all these fun little
Halloween things with you know masks and
doing all these little side fun missions
that you can never do in Halo so what
about what do you think about Mike
where's your goddamn halo 5 Halloween
mask at well they do do like special
event playlists for multiplayer okay
can't swap out well yeah you can you can
do different aesthetic appearance is now
in Halo 4 and 5 and 3 and reach but yeah
they don't have the certain ones that
are actually designed to really pull you
back in although halo 5 the DLC models
the free maps that they'll just keep
introducing throughout the year but I
that's the thing for halo I feel like
when I play destiny I return almost out
of obligation I know you yourself call
them chores just as it like certain
things like completely bounties doing
arms day I in Halo I returned because I
want to because I think it's fun and
it's not something that I feel forced to
come back to because I'm gonna miss like
the weekend that sir is selling
Gjallarhorn or you know like power
weapons like that Halo I just I think
the gameplay itself is enough to bring
me back and I think that's a little more
what I want out of games something that
doesn't demand that I come back it's
just something that encouraged me
and yeah I agree with Tay I think you
know Bungie does a great job of you know
keeping its community involved with
these cool like events that just come
out of nowhere but I don't know halo I
think just the purity of its gameplay
has more longevity for me mmm and let's
talk about I guess the amount of variety
that's in each game because that's at
least when I think about multiplayer
inhaler or I think of a halo generally
throughout him Forge obviously in
December a lot of different ways to play
that game and do you think that that's
the same in destiny do you think kalo
has sort of a has more content as it was
it work or do you think destiny does if
you were to like take everything into
again here to take everything into
account I think destiny has more by
volume but I think halo is from each but
just again going back to like each match
itself I think especially with warzone
introduced now it's that PvE and PvP I
don't know how much you like warzone and
how much you played it but you know it's
just more that I could use this emergent
gameplay that happens when you're like
you know going for a certain ball AI
boss or going for a certain capture
point it's just there's a lot of options
like chase after and then arena you have
a bunch of different game modes and I
think there's a lot of variety and it
changes up how the games unfold a lot
whereas I think I feel like destiny a
lot of times is like these chores that
might get me a slightly better weapon or
just might be like let's exotic bounty
chain that I'm chasing for a week or two
it sounds like for Halo the journey is
the reward whereas in destiny that may
be the journey is a means to an end to
the reward is that fair to say um a
little bit uh I think again just using
the word evolved because that's what
I've been doing I mean evolved is better
than both of these games you can no
definitely not let's just not even go
there but what like here's a kind of
cool thing that has happened in the
taken King there there have been these
little missions that come up daily
missions that come up that all of a
sudden if if you unlock some of these
secrets then you actually kind of go
down this path for a special mission
that gets you a special weapon and
they've had like two of those now and
those are like super awesome and I think
just part of it too is I like the
weapons in destiny more they're more
unique I think again it is like a you've
invested the time to get them so I feel
more affinity with them right and I
still think the the like no knock on the
sound and the the sound of the gunplay
in Halo
I think it's pretty good too but like
there's just something about when I hear
a hawk and get shot or a boolean Gemini
like I can tell like what gun I'm
shooting because like it just has a
unique sound and it's awesome but yeah I
mean like you do I there are chores
things that like but there are things
that are built-in to try to get you to
come back and and like I feel like
there's like so many now that I don't
even come back to do them all which is
like a good or a bad thing depending on
how you look at it but that means
there's always something to do right
like here's something like court of
works it's part of Destiny's taking king
expansion that was not in the game where
you and potentially nine stranger or
eight other strangers or two other
people on your fireteam could do if you
wanted to to you know get some loot or
just have some fun together so they just
have so many activities you can do and
they also have PvP modes that they come
every like month or two for iron banner
or they have like a more serious one in
trials of Osiris where it's the more
competitive mode of like here's three on
three
almost like wow arena style you know the
higher you get the better items you get
and yeah you are chasing stuff but I
think that's part of I guess maybe the
addiction I'll admit that that's fine
like that's part of when your why is
right that's why you're playing the game
though but it's it's one that keeps
growing and they keep adding more things
as long as you can pay for it what would
you say to that
yeah I think by and large is just halo
and halo 5 especially it always it
destiny undoubtedly has more to do I
think I just feel as if halos is more
worth doing again because I don't feel
obligated I don't feel like I'm missing
out if I'm not playing it's just all on
my terms and I'm coming back at my own
leisure and I think it's I think
inherently it's not designed the same
way as destiny I think Bungie did a
great job and encouraging people to
stick around and come back but I think
3/4 II did a better job with Halo 5 to
actually just make me love playing it
and just in terms of you're right up to
now like there has been a lot of money
spent on destiny again it's like a value
proposition for me I think it's fine for
me because I enjoy I spent a lot of time
so the the money spent is not that bad
but I will say they have added
microtransactions which is kind of weird
but it doesn't affect the game so I'm
totally fine with its emotes it's stuff
like that dances you know and
not that you can buy for silver and I've
heard that they're testing these emotes
and these microtransactions because they
might use these the funds they make from
this to give free story DLC and stuff
like that going forward and so maybe
this Halloween event that they had
that's pretty big is like a test case of
let's see you know what the people how
much they spend and like if they spend
enough money maybe you won't pay for
DLCs anymore and the whales can maybe
pay for everyone else yeah doesn't it
seem where it did a company that sorry
I'm being I'm supposed to be that's my
heart not you know have no partisanship
in this and but if you talk about a team
that's has a 10-year contract with
Activision to make a game who employs
+200 people to really think DLC sales is
what's going to make them making story
and for the game I mean it's possible I
again like that's just what I've seen in
stories like I've been put out exactly
so it's it's it that could those could
just be missions or events right like
but it is a it's a nice little it's just
interesting I think like half because
both of you enjoy both games and think
there's pluses and minuses of both but
it seems like so much of it has got to
that got to be down to like the way we
play whereas like you kind of wanted an
experience where you don't feel
criticized for not keeping up with us
where you don't feel like you're being
manipulated and you can go in have some
fun and then leave whereas you're very
much into the idea of having a like a
character that's yours which you
couldn't have in Halo because you
couldn't have a character that has the
gun that you earned and like the rep
that you earned and then you know
various currencies and level that you
work as if you were playing Halo then
you basically be hitting reset largely
and every single time you had to play it
do you think it's like it's just like a
different strokes for different folks
kind of situation probably I I mean like
I I thought halo 5 campaign was like
pretty good like it that was okay I
think some of the story and and some of
the marketing for it wasn't me you know
like it kind of got me there and I think
war zones kind of fun if you have enough
people but again you can have like weird
experiences with any PvP FPS where you
get rolled and you're just like well
that sucked
game but you know in destiny you end up
being able to play single-player if
you're not a PvP berth so
you you like